I'm Laura Kiesel and I have chronic pain
and I work as a freelance writer and
editor the onset of chronic pain was
really gradual for me it didn't happen
suddenly with an accident or anything in
particular I was born with a really
severe case of clubfoot I had to have as
a child several surgeries and wear a
cast until I was three and that left me
with some structural discrepancies and
issues in my body like I have my leg is
shorter on my left side than my right
and the the muscles in it are
underdeveloped and the foot has no arch
and is sort of pronated so over time as
I got older I had more and more stress
on my hips and my low spine so I always
had some pain as a child and as a
teenager but it hasn't been until the
past several years that it's become just
daily it was usually more sporadic or
intermittent growing up I also have
unrelated to that endometriosis which is
a disease a reproductive disease related
to like menstruation so starting in high
school I started getting very painful
periods and it wasn't until I was 24
that I was able to finally get surgery
to have a lot of it removed and have it
diagnosed but I had so I had pain during
those days and I had some other pain but
it wasn't daily until the past few years
where I've started to have a lot of
degenerative changes in my hips and
spine they think partially from that
discrepancy from my legs and just the
wear and tear as you grow older of
walking with those kind of structural
abnormalities kind of wearing on my body
so when when pain becomes a daily
reality it can be a very like hollowing
almost a humanizing experience after a
while because it's just you wake up and
you're still in pain and you go to bed
and you're still in pain and
you don't sleep well because you because
you're in pain so it can it can be very
distracting I think it's very hard until
you've had that be your daily reality to
realize how much it can affect your
concentration affect your mobility
affect your ability to do things that
you took for granted so so many things
that used to come very easily to me now
take a lot of effort and even sometimes
just bandwidth like the mental or
emotional bandwidth to deal with
something when I have a really bad pain
day is much lower on some days than
others some days I just can't handle a
workload at all and I just need to be in
bed or just take it easy and other days
I'll have a good day but even if I'm
very productive usually it's like then I
run on a deficit the following days for
having a high energy day it's never
nothing is ever free anymore it's like
you're running constantly on a certain
amount of borrowed time and bandwidth
and physical energy or tolerance to pain
I've only been offered not even really
what's considered pain medication
primarily but things like anticonvulsant
like gabapentin and lyrica which are
primarily for epilepsy but now are being
used for people with fibromyalgia and
nerve pain so I've tried those I didn't
have they didn't really help much they
took the edge off a little but not much
and then the side-effects kind of
outweighed any benefit so I stopped
taking them after a few months
other than NS aids or like ibuprofen and
and Tylenol
like I don't really have much else
that's been offered to me the only time
opioids have really been offered to me I
know now they're cutting back so it
might be the timing with which my
chronic pain has really blown up has
been really acute situations where
they've only given me a few days worth
if I've like when my disk first
herniated like I got a few days worth of
codeine the only thing I take
semi-regularly
is I take a flexural which is a muscle
relaxant a few nights a week when I
really need to try to sleep through the
pain most people I know in my chronic
pain group and friends who have had
similar issues are on opioids or at
least wore for time an extended period
of time but because I have a family
history of addiction
I really prevalent family history of
addiction to opioid drugs I did not want
to take that so I've never really
inquired and even when I have four very
acute situations like when I've in like
when my discs first got injured I made
sure to ask for like the lowest type in
the lowest dose because I just don't
want to even risk going down any kind of
pathway to addiction similar to like my
family members my mother was a heroin
addict she did not start with opioids
she she started straight from
experimenting with different drugs like
cocaine and then started with heroin and
she became a heroin addict my brother so
my mother was a heroin addict for many
years and then she got on a methadone
program and she wasn't on heroin anymore
but when she became a cancer patient and
she had terminal cancer for many years
it was terminal but it was it it was
five years before she died she was given
an opioid prescription I don't think
they did any evaluation of her history
or maybe they also figured just because
she is terminal to overlook her history
but my brother was in the household with
her she started giving him her pills so
he became addicted to dilaudid and when
she died he actually suffered very badly
from withdrawal because he suddenly
didn't have access to her prescriptions
anymore he took to the streets and he
got arrested and it he finally had to
check himself in for a couple of days
and then he got on suboxone and and got
off opioid